each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
this work isn't actually my work it was
done by susana Avila Casilla but
unfortunately she decided to get married
instead of coming to present it so
you've got me instead but i would ask
your it these are patients with me on
where i'm not entirely am flush with
everything i'll try to answer any
questions you have bird mmm yeah okay so
a quick outline when i talk about at
first i'm going to look at correct or
cancer and why this is a significant
issue and then going to look at some of
the work that's being done in oxford to
address this problem and after that I'll
talk about a the various bits of the
project and before looking at the few
challenges that we have with expect to
face and are facing and our future work
and conclusions so starting off correct
or cancer aim is diagnosing about 36,000
people every year in the UK making it
the third most common cancer and to make
it worse than it quite regularly spreads
to the liver and this results in an
additional three thousand deaths every
year and it's normally detected through
a range of scanning techniques such as
CT ultrasound MRI and once it's been
detected you then monitor if they
continue to monitor it like that decide
whether to do surgery or whether yeah
the radiotherapy or the various other
options that are available for dealing
with it and so once you've got these
images though you need to there's a lot
of work done on the analysis of them so
too if not so we're looking at various
different a algorithms to assist in this
because for instance you want to segment
you know the image so that you can tell
the different bits are so you'd want to
for instance draw a line around the
bladder here as the contractile and
you've got the hip bones out on either
side but the problem we're doing this is
it's fine to do it for a single image
but normally you're looking at sets of
images where you want to go around all
of the different parts of the image and
calculate the volume of the cancer and
see whether it's growing we also want to
do image registration because it's all
very well being able to segment the
image up into the different pieces but
if you
a set of images of you now and there's
another set of images in six months time
most thing things like your skeleton is
such like will stay put but your bladder
will move according to how much liquids
in it at any given moment and you need
to be able to get all this lineup again
once you're dealing with large sense of
images there are better things to pay
highly qualified surgeons to do than
going through and going all those too
much up there too much and so there's a
lot of work going on on automated and
semi-automated algorithms for instance
you say in one image these are that's
the bladder and matching up this murder
and then it goes to the other images
being able to work out and automatically
segment them and you put points around
the Sun I'm saying this is the alone we
want to draw lines on it and also
there's the improvement of the image
quality because images tend to be quite
noisy very highly textured and also you
end up with a fairly poor contrast to
the surroundings in the raw images and
you see always looking to see how you
can improve the quality of that and so
this is also research in Oxford going
towards how to do these in different and
better algorithm to improve these images
and so in with the aim of helping out on
this a Microsoft two of the projects
that are currently funded by Microsoft
I'm well aware that there are many
others and include the top one which is
developing new segmentation algorithms
to do automatic segmentation and then
all I'm going to talk about today we're
we're actually looking at is a how to
make it easier to take advantage of the
research that's going on both for
clinicians and for other medical
researchers so at the moment you know
people tend to work on their own they
publish papers occasionally budem it
takes a long time for things to come
round and once the informations come
round it takes a lot of you're getting
hold of the raw data and the algorithm
then pulling all the papers and the
documentation together so that you can
get it all to work it's quite
challenging so there's a looking at how
to do that and also looking at how to
make it easier to do things like the
inserting the human element to the semi
automatic algorithms but I'm going to
talk about that later okay
so in order to make it simpler to do to
handle all of this we're looking to
divide we've designed the framework
which we're looking to implement that
will allow the researchers to share both
the data and the algorithms that they
stored it will bring in all the papers
and I'm just suffered a name I'm a
visualization tool so everything
basically pulling everything together
into one place and making it universally
shareable both within the university
across the country and ideally across
the world but I'm this intention is to
build this on top of a cloud computing
framework so that it can scale up nice
you we don't have to decide how big a
cluster we want to build in the first
place we can as and when you want to
explain that you can just buy more space
on whoever's constitute or cloud
framework we're using and we're also
looking at how to make it easier to put
in the information and I'm not going to
talk about that today if you want to
come and see about the work they're
doing on that there's a talk on it on
Wednesday and what we'll talk about the
various and experiments we've done with
alternative ways of inputting data and
so the aim is like I said to build on
top of an existing on top of existing
cloud work so we because we don't want
to have to write everything out from
scratch and reproduce stuff that lots of
other people have produced before so we
want to take where possible the work
that's already exists in cloud computing
and then just layer on top the extra
bits that we require so for instance we
hope to be able to get things like
ultimate the setup for publishing the
web services to access this framework
and directly from a cloud computing
framework we would expect to be able to
get some of the security features that
will need in order to control access to
the data from such a framework and the
ability to store certain amounts of
metadata we're also expect not to be
able to get all the metadata storage and
the problem of storage that we would
want to go with this and we may not be
able to get all of the security
information program and the interactions
with the various toolkit so
that we're what we're hoping to do is
layer a cloud on top of the cloud
effectively so we look at the structure
of what it is we're planning to layer on
top of I'm so at the moment the M
researchers are using a sort of a jumble
of a different languages a different
experimental data sets and they publish
all the results and they go out on the
web and so we'd like to be able to do
all this together and then connect it to
the various toolkits that they're
already using and so as to make it
easier to tie together all the image
analysis and all in one place so it's
easier to gain access to you can just
install it from a client running on
whatever system and it comes across as a
rich application on the web either is a
thin client or just to a browser and
having done that we would like to layer
the aims at night microsoft workflow
over the top of that to provide a means
of tying together these different tool
kits and transferring and bits of work
between them that also praises the
potential of an researchers publishing
the workflows that they've got em to tie
together existing algorithms and then
these being yeah you can then start
building this up as a stroke hierarchy
of workflows to get to the final
solutions that you're looking for and
what we then want to make that all
accessible through a layer of metadata
and a set of web services so that you
can run it either through a web-based
application so you shall research
environment something like that and one
of the scientific work benches that many
of them of which are available so you
have run workbench on your computer but
the actual jobs will get sent off over
the web services to run in a cloud
somewhere accessing data that's against
or not in the cloud or finally through
an enriched desktop application and all
this is to mne with the medical
researcher and that the medical in the
image analysis people to make better use
of the resources are available i spend
more time doing the research rather than
trying to piece together bits and pieces
of information from papers and websites
in
yeah emailing rail because somebody
managed to leave out a file which was
important for running the algorithm but
they didn't realize they've got it in a
desktop so specific applications that
we're looking and projects that we're
looking to work with this there's the
reef or the virtual environment and the
web-based stuff there's the work that's
been done with my experiment with Carmen
and with the research information center
aim for the work scientific workflows
and work benches there's trevenna and
there's a Microsoft workflow foundation
and and there were many others out there
but those are the two that we're
focusing on at the moment and then for a
enriched applications as things like ski
run which enables you to do very
impressive and high quality
visualizations of the work that you're
looking at obviously you don't want to
be able to sending all of that over the
net so you would want to send the data
to the enriched application and then let
it calculate the visualization locally
and then there's things like MATLAB
which and they seem very hung very keen
to hang onto matlab and they like it a
lot but yeah I mean we may end up seeing
our something like that turning up there
at some point in the future but for the
time being at least not that so to do
this would using a some among the tools
were using we used in the following
microsoft also visual studio is
currently used for a lot of the c++
programming which the medical
researchers use and it makes this would
make it very easy to attach onto the web
services that are but we propose to make
available and to wrap up then the dotnet
platform also it is really useful
because it allows you know they've been
writing their code in a range of
different languages and it allows us to
join those together without having and
lots and lots of complications about how
to run different pieces of code and have
to go down to the file system or
streaming across through sockets between
code it just simplifies the interaction
of the different pieces and we also want
to collaborate with the existing virtual
research environment project a
hallucinogen formation center so the
major challenges that are facing us with
this project
aim to build on the work that people
have done so far is how to adapt things
like the research the existing research
environments the various imaging tool
kits which I was given a long list of
names and all of them have escaped me at
the moment I apologize a and algorithms
developed by researchers so they can all
be embedded within this framework a how
to link to the repository so that yeah
we we don't end up setting up an
entirely separate system again because
there's enough lots of trees except
there already but we don't want to go
and set up a new one what we want to do
is be is make a single point where you
can interact with all these different
resources that are out there because
it's in the Oxford has a policy that
everything we publish has to go into the
Oxford repository I suspect that's true
of most universities and so we want to
have a method so that these repositories
which are based on institutions can be
tied together to be based on communities
and we also want to engage with the
users because a lot of the medical image
analysis people get very excited once
you start to show them what could be
done but they are entirely unaware of
the existence of these possibilities and
so want to engage with them but we also
want to engage with the students and the
computer scientists and because a lot of
them are too aware of this is an area
where research is a possibility and so
the problem remains an address through
ignorance rather than it being too
boring and too trivial whatever to be
deemed worth their while and so we want
we want to encourage that be an
interaction between these two
communities so people can talk about
what what is possible and what they can
even want to achieve and yeah also
encourage people to go and have a look
at the problems so for the future work
and there's the acceptance and so we
need to examine the existing software
and work out how we can wrap that and
how we can tie all of that together and
tie it into our framework if we're going
to do that we need to come up with a set
of designs for having evaluated the work
we need
to come up with a set of designs for how
we can pass and store this data and we
want to always obviously be able to turn
it into a single format but if you have
a set of formats at least then we know
what translators we need to produce and
how we how we need to be able to
transfer the data across the designer
that how to implement the different
workflow engines and so they all come
they've got their different engines and
you can put month clouds but we need to
work out how how exactly we're going to
find that into the project and then lay
that's on top of the image tool kits etc
and and then having yeah as I say
incorporate that with the existing image
toolkits and finally and link to the
permanent repositories and so to
conclude I feel I probably rushed
through this far too quickly with live
presented the outline for this framework
and we've detailed and where we propose
to go with it next in the future work
that we need to do in order to turn this
from a dream into something approaching
a reality hopefully entirely approaching
reality in fact Werdum we'll see how far
we wanted to go down this list and
finally I guess I should thank the
people whose work this actually is and
our attempt to answer any questions that
you have so we
and well I see you pondering what your
next question is going to be out I'll
start us off we hear a lot of people
talking about cloud over the these last
couple of days we don't hear as many
people talking about client and if we
think about chipsets and the development
of chipsets the power of the chipset is
going to be both in the cloud and in the
client and so a hypothetical question if
you had a hundred times more computing
power tomorrow what would you do with it
and I wouldn't romantically improve
increase the resolution of the images
we're working with because often the
images that actually come out of the
machines get downsized in order to be
realistically analyzable and that's
something I prolly should have mentioned
this one of the hopes with the cloud
framework is that will then have extra
resources available so if you if the
clinician is looking at something in
this cited sites that the resolution
isn't high enough for them because they
often they can make the decision without
having to look at it to the extreme
detail but if they look at something in
there like well I really I want to have
a high resolution of that they can just
hit the button and you'll be able to get
the the higher resolution and ideally
with more computing power then I want a
much higher resolution and of course
with more computing power the CT
scanners and suchlike will be able to do
much better analysis of the raw data
that they're recording and so you'll get
a high resolution there so it's going to
be it's an arms race between the two and
but it definitely high resolution would
be with my collection over here
it's all so real and you basically using
this crowd computing web services space
through cloud computing how big is the
data side you're talking about you know
mmrr image can be very big so that I
always got always be a big problem so
how can you handle these kind of things
I mean the hope is that most of the data
once it's got across onto the club can
stay there and all you'll be sending
back is the bit that you actually are
looking at any given time in the same
way as the talker laQuan talks early on
though I don't know with you in that
we're talking about how they visualizing
terabyte astronomical data looking at
black matter and doing a very similar
technique to Microsoft or Google Maps
where you you calculate the little bits
that you want to send over and yeah
because the screen size remains constant
and you've got this huge data set behind
it but you actually end up saturating
the screen and so you only need to go to
the resolution the screens working at
not the resolution that the data set is
originally stored up and then just
because once you zoom in you can crop
away all the stuff around the side and
you still end up with in and much
smaller data set that is feasible to
move around of course yeah as screen
sizes improve again just have you have
to sort of hope that network is going to
keep up to an extent but we'll see where
things go and any last questions well
thank you so much we appreciate it round
of applause